salut aujourd'hui je suis avec yacine
bonjour yacine belhousse vos bonjour
j'étais enchanté yacine belhousse fabien
olicard j'ai depuis longtemps une envie
de croiser le mentaliste mais le vaudou
choisi pour ça il me faut un mec
le mec gentil par excellence tu vois on
peut faire du gentil vaudou on va faire
du gentil vaudois déjà on va agresser
personne on va on va agresser une petite
poupée car ça va elles sont toutes pic à
des endroits différents
je te fais voir et puis je vous le fais
pour enregistrer des petites taches de
200 quand même un ont peu apprécié ce
coup là ça semble voilà il ya eu des
petits problèmes
alors il y en a une qui ait pas de
l'intérieur oui mais tu es à l'intérieur
de cette enveloppe la télé alors ça on
verra si le vaudou fonctionne inclus on
aura peut-être une espèce de
synchronicité entre les deux d'accord
qu'il a peur étant moins que tu ne la
longueur est en toi est ce que tu peux
les retourner à les mélanger entre elles
je peux faire les deux mais je vais
d'abord les mélanger comme ça mais
mélange tu veux le même toi tu saches
plus là la vraie manger peut être aurait
on les a niés dans noir et pas moi je
les regarde là d'ailleurs que l'hôtel
dieu voilà peut-être toi tu arrives à
genre on regarde on a un truc à te
souvenir d'un employé sur j'aime
vraiment déjà géo bkx été découpé et
mais qu'est ce que je faisais ça je sais
plus ce que je fais là alors est-ce
qu'on va bien tout à l'image oui ça
permet cette assertion célèbre carte ici
voix bon on va même les étals et un
petit peu un deux trois quatre clichés y
en a 7 7 alors pour commencer on va en
choisir une qui sera qui sera l'élu
c'est à dire que quoi qu'il arrive on
sait qu'il va pas lui arriver du mal
donc tu mets ton doigt sur une des sept
cartes celle que tu celle ci il arrivera
pas de mal on va pas l'appliquer on va
pas la vaudoise et c'est là qu'elle que
tu nous arrive et c'est tant mieux
c'était bien celle là dans l'ue en
partie des parties intimes ou le nombril
ça fait mal donc on enlève celle-ci ok
maintenant tu vas me faire deux tas de
taboye de table 3 c'est toi qui choisis
que je chipote bien je sais capitaine
chipotage un accord à trois tu choisis
qui lequel tu as et piles et le capte à
effacer on va sélectionner à pile ou
face pile face donc pile puis efface
déjà ça une pièce d'un euro
est-ce qu'on peut mettre la musique à la
fille
face à wayne c'est la fia musique
parfaite pour ça j'ai sorti une pièce
d'un euro qui est pile d'un côté et face
de l'autre donc tu va la faire tourner
ok et tu m'as dit si c'est pile c'est ce
talent a hésité face on gardera stade
c'est totalement ça on gardera le tas
auprès des marchés ou alors tu sais les
faire tourner je suis à lille comme dans
les saloons effet à deux doigts comme ça
what are you avec un soin j'arrive comme
sartre asie c'est pas mal
sérieux avec comme ça c'est pas mal ici
c'est une machine sociale s'épiler
essais il t'a dit pile c'est celui-là
est là donc celle ci on les enlève
je serai savoir et ses pieds le ressens
tu veux oui la tête mais c'est embêtant
mais bram en tennis il ya pas pierre
mondy et de cupola tant mieux le coeur
ça va pour l'instant on reste le plus
grand chose à l'histoire fait voir deux
étant un élimine une base la voix ça me
va très bien tes limites celles qu'on va
mettre à côté avec les autres grecs ou
des deux une des deux on élimine
celle-là on élimine celle avec la main
gauche
un fait à ma gauche c'est un bouche à
main la main côté coeur et d'une tout ce
qui bouge sauver wet tous les goûts et
j'aime pas trop je suis surdouée gauche
donc peut-être ça viendra peut-être
c'est ça c'est bien mais c'est pas vrai
c'est moi j'ai un problème dans votre
genre tentant un tigre en fait un jour
noir la cie cicérone pilote dans le
spectacle à les voir en spectacle
allez le voir respecter je vous tue
reprend quant à paris je reprends j'ai
une date le 22 novembre à l'européen
tellement triste elle salsa meyers
important des six jeunes à bien ouais
j'suis trop tendre la main
il a un plateau à la nouvelle scène et
qui reprend le 26 septembre
oui avec certains favoris car je vais
tester un nouveau numéro là bas 1 et
c'est nouveau et ça ce qu'il reste de on
retourne sur un pile ou face
wei qui détient les otages c'est quoi
celle là je n'aime pas trop et donc du
coup quelle façon dickie pilecki fabien
une phase il fasse ouais mais ça va être
pire ça s'efface ça c'est pil pil face
aux quais alors elle se rappelait alors
toujours la même chose à celle qui
tombera sur la pièce est celle qu'on
élimine élimine
au fur et à mesure exactement d'acheter
comme sais pas ce que j'ai fait mais ça
a tourné un peu tourner le fascicule du
show
ça va peut-être la même chose ouah ça
lance-t-il
j'ai insisté ça change des cycliques et
ses fidèles à toute façon que je me pose
c'est vrai j'avais dit oui en écoutant
les objets j'ai eu très très peur quand
j'ai les boules rouges trois ans et j'ai
pas encore vu le pic en fait au départ
j'ai vu que la boule rouge
ah oui non non non non c'est douloureux
nous ont fait passer à un faux pas dans
les trucs le pied droit donkey pied ne
reste plus que tu ne leur reste plus que
je ne sais pas si elle a été vous
divisez la pièce il sait vraiment où
rollier et où je sais pas s'il ya de la
synchro nice le délire ces gens que ça
c'est ça alors je ne sais même plus ce
que j'ai mis dedans en fait j'en ai pris
j'ai deux jeux de photos comme saïd anti
que j'ai pris j'en ai mis une au hasard
là dedans et je suis on verra avec qu'il
ya sinon on va faire des illuminations
jusqu'au bout quoi c'est le moment où tu
me fais peur un peu après tu penses que
tu es une sorcière et toujours on ouvre
on a un c'est un bout de carton ainsi un
but carton
tu peut le vérifier il ya que du carton
est donc là c'est la main droite qui
était un gros atout là tu le sens un peu
il ya un côté jésus un derrière c'est la
main droite qui a été piquée en 16 votes
servat était en cours sans quoi c'est ça
derrière on n'a pas vu le nom n'a pas
encore vu main droite passe et ouais
c'est vrai donc du goût de tous et non
pour tous
déjà fait peur c'est une sorcière parce
qu'il paraît que c'est le mec qui joue
avec le vaudou donc il se prend lé sort
après j'ai cassé ma jeune étoile et moi
j'y arrive je pense même que c'est le
seul endroit où tu auras pas mal et tout
le reste va s'abattre
franchement je suis superstitieux mais
c'est vrai oui [ __ ] mais c'est trop
fort ça ça va plus ça m'a plu mais c'est
quoi le flippant parce que vraiment il y
en ait je suis beaucoup moins fort on
arrivé là j'ai choisi d'état je l'avais
la pierre merci beaucoup et yacine
algérien merci à toi yachvili-parra
montréal là il est juste venu faire la
vidéo en ville c'était super de c'était
génial mais c'est énervant parce qu'on
ne sait pas comment tu as fait non moi
je commence à être énervé parce que j'ai
un doute sur le fait que j'ai tout
maîtriser ouais je suis tombé moi je me
fais reprendre c'est qu'on a vraiment
maîtrise maryse et alain suguenot sa
fête
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous a plu
vendredi je fais une vidéo je mentalise
quelqu'un de la chaîne l'un d'eux
retrouveront peut-être que toi juste là
derrière l'écran tenez vous au courant
domaine sur les réseaux sociaux sur
twitter sur facebook chance à g /
snapshot je vous annoncerai comment on
va faire pour jouer activement participé
à la mentalisation de vendredi en
parlant de réseaux sociaux n'hésitez pas
à rajouter yacine sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'ils postent coup les
postes souvent vous pouvez également
laisser un petit commentaire pour nous
dire ce que vous en avez pensé si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo vous pouvez
laisser un diabolique hebdo is an ou
sans l'air n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
avant de partir puisque le mental boxe
et une vidéo par jour pendant un an donc
rendez vous demain 17h à ciao